السنه كانت سنه مثيره للجدل جدا اا يمكن
احنا كان عندنا احداث كثير في مصر كرويا
متوفقناش في كاس امم افريقيا ولا تاهلنا
لكاس العالم
والصدفه في المبارتين ان احنا خسرنا قدام
السنغال بضربات الجزاء بس ده ما منعش
وجودنا في كاس العالم بقوه لان الكوره كاس
العالم كانت صناعه مصريه وكمان كان في
مشاركه فنيه من فرح الديبانى ووكس في حفل
الافتتاح وطبعا يعني وجودهم اضاف همم يعني
طابع كده خاص جدا للحفل اا على الصعيد
كمان الفني كان في احداث كثير مثيره للجدل
على صعيد العلاقات زي ما انتم قلتم من
شويه علاقه حسام وشيرين وعلاقه من عرفه
وكمان الدرس كود اللي احنا شفناه الزاني
في مهرجان القاهره وقسم الناس بين مؤيد
ومعارض للاسف ودعنا فنانين كتير زي مها
ابو عوف هشام سليم سمير صبري ودعنا كمان
همم المحامي الكبير فريده الديب اللي قبل
ما يتوفى على طول كان متصدر همم
همم يعني كثير من عناوين الاخبار بعد
اعلان ان هو همم هيدافع عن قاتل نيره اشرف
وطبعا دي اا نوع من الجرائم احنا بنتمنى
نودعه في 20 23 هو وكل الجرايم تماما
اا احنا يمكن بلد فيها احداث كتير وترندات
كتير بس احنا ما شفناش السنه دي اطول من
التراند بتاع عامل النظافه اللي اتطرد من
محل الكشري يعني اعتقد ان ده التريند اللي
مكمل معنا ل23 وان شاء الله يعني السنه
الجديده هاغطي معكم اخبار اسعد ومغامرات
اكثر واشوفكم دائما بخير كل عام وانت بالف
خير يا ندى من القاهره ندى حجازي